i want to warn you it's going to send a
little bit of a shock this
is definitely an attack it will affect
your child rearing
it will affect your education system
and then you're looking at muhammad or
aisha's fingers is yellow and there's
some smell coming out and you're like
man are my kids on drugs
i want to save my kids what is happening
in these public institutions
so they can see we're not making this
stuff up as i read through the ethnic
study model curriculum
on the framework i was very concerned
because i believe it's a trojan horse
using race as a smokescreen
to bring in pedophilia
subscribe if you haven't already such an
important topic that we're going to be
discussing
education and our children
who many of us would die for we love our
children and then you send them off
to get an education to the schooling
system and then you associate with
school
all the good things they're going to
learn how to read how to write
how to add and subtract the next thing
you know
they're coming back and they're
developing some other things along the
way
friends you're losing some control
they're around certain friends that you
know
are influencing them into some things
that
majority of things that you don't
approve of they're learning a different
language and it's not spanish or
french but actually they're dropping
f-bombs and then you're looking at
muhammad or ayesha's fingers it's
yellow and there's some smell coming out
and you're like man are my kids on drugs
oh my god and then most importantly
you've got a whole institution
set up preaching and teaching one of the
most
illogical things that you can do that
there's no creator oh
subhanallah so how do we combat this
well
we got our next not one not
two not even three well we got three to
start with then we're gonna also
have a surprise guest for these three
that don't even know about the surprise
guest so let's bring
him on one two three
assalamu alaikum
so we got sheikh imam kareem we got dr
hassan and we got sheikh dr ahmed
we're going to start off with this video
clip i'm going to show we're going to
get right into it
and it's kind of it's i want to warn you
it's going to send a little bit of a
shock
but the shock is there to inshallah
produce something good
a good discussion because many parents
teachers and even maybe some imams
people out there
they're not hip to what's really going
on and then we're going to bring a
surprise guest
to really get to the bottom of what's
being promoted
in the public institution the public
schools
and at the end we'll give a solution to
all that you guys ready
absolutely
this is definitely an attack it will
affect your child rearing
it will affect your education system
this is instructions for the teacher in
the classroom
to ask her or his students how do people
express their sexual feelings what is
abstinence and here are some answers
oral sex
masturbation anal sex massage holding
hands
touching each other's genitals saying i
like you
and what they're doing is equating all
these things
saying i like you is equal to anal sex
it is pornography men especially on the
house floor did not want to look at
we couldn't show this on the television
news but yet we want our fourth grade
children to be looking at this book in
the name of sexuality education
children are seeing obscene materials
that have been ruled by congress and by
the supreme court
impossible to show to children an online
csc program for african youth called the
world starts with me
tells children that sexuality includes
oral sex and masturbation it then tells
them
it's their own choice if they want to
lose their virginity it shows children
pictures of naked girls and boys
in various stages of development and
then ask them to point out differences
in their private parts
parents likely will never know as it is
all done
online away from home they have
elementary students as
young as nine years old then they teach
them how to wear a condom
and they have this plastic genitalia and
they even have
young girls they're teaching them how to
put a condom on a male genitalia and
boys how to put a condom on a woman
genitalia without the
knowledge and consent of the parents now
i felt i
felt honestly a little bit uh shy to go
ahead and uh
or you know it kind of uh but this is
what's happening
what are you guys reaction when you see
this
did you guys know what do you guys know
about this what's happening in the
public schools what they're teaching
allah
i'm aware of sexual education and uh
in the schooling system but to that
extent
i know that's a little bit shocking for
me i mean the language the
i mean this is this is extremely i mean
you know the one thing that can really
be mutually
received from all the prophets as a
unified message that
if if you if you don't shy if you don't
have shyness
you say you know that what is the
what is the bashfulness here it's sad
so what do you what do you think dr
hassan when you see something like this
many people
they're kind of just uh not hip to
what's going on you know the parent
comes to america say we made it
our son daughter is going to become a
doctor and engineer and they put him
into this
these institutions the public schools
and then next thing you know
uh they may even change their gender or
they're announcing they're not
denouncing their faith
have you had some experience with this
yeah very unfortunate i mean uh
i don't know 10 years ago i was
or more actually i would say i was in
connecticut uh
25 years ago and i was like uh
responsible for the uh part of the
school system in the stratford in new
jersey
and actually connecticut and i um
one day i was in the uh nursing office
in the in a school
and i saw that sign which says sex
is uh a fruit of a a fruit
basket if you eat too much you're going
to get sick
so that's an open invitation for for
kids in the in the
um middle school to have sexuality
uh and of course um i mean if you do too
much you're gonna get sick but if you do
some obviously uh it's it's good for you
um has been uh uh like a curve
since like 25 or even 30 years ago
and things has been like uh being
promoted more and more with more
uh graphics uh or graphic language in
in the uh pub supposed to see the effect
of this
in my practice as a pediatrician uh on
and on
and uh it's very hard actually to deal
with it
uh for all the children uh dr
uh ahmed your comments
i am shocked to the point that i'm
out of words to see young children being
introduced
to something like that and while you are
at this young age building their morale
and their
system their moral system and their
understanding of life
you start to introduce him to all these
ideas
that can destroy them completely and
lead them again
go out of their way to commit
all these acts of
of haram as muslim or as human being
which is not really good for any child
to know all of these
kind of ideas uh dr kareem you have a
lot of experience also
tell us i mean you've also had what what
are some of the things that you're
seeing
you know from the the parents when they
send them into some of these
institutions
you know some of these things like you
just said i mean you've been exposed to
it but not to this extent
can you share some stories some
practical stories also
from some things that just were just
like are just becoming
uh and it seems like people are becoming
more desensitized
to it but at first it's such a shock
well being an imam and
getting the first-hand phone call from
parents regarding
crisis family crisis
in this situation we hear many stories
two fronts here are being threatened
through the current school system
the first front is the faith
of our kids no one can deny that
america is promoting
the idea that you can be successful
without god
god has no place in your life and this
is
what is summed up in that
line separation between the church and
the state
of course in our case here the masjid
and the state
basically they are saying we do not
teach religion
but then parents they wake up with the
fact that they
teach a religion uh what is the name of
that religion
no religion which is now called atheism
so all that the textbook uh is designed
uh to remove god from the equation
completely
um things can happen on their own
you will ideally hear energy created
still
deals beside the uh color the rays
the the language as if the the genes
act in its own so imagine you pin your
child
to this school system for almost 12
years
and being brainstormed so
what do you expect if you send your
child to a catholic school he's going to
come out catholic
if you send your child to a public
school system without
i want to make a reservation here
because listen if you can
filter out what they learned and fix it
in my opinion this is the ideal approach
but who who can do that it's we were not
qualified to do this as parents many of
us
uh but they come out and they denounce
uh islam they they renounce they say i'm
no longer a muslim
and they even and i received that phone
call from many parents my
my son uh posted on his facebook page
uh or his instagram that he's now an
atheist
or he's looking for a religion and and
so forth
that's the first grant eddie that that
is being threatened
the second front is the moral front
which is you started the show with
um we send our children to that public
school system and
they are walking or swimming against um
current that is so high it's it's
impossible
that they can uh uh face it
uh and at the end of the day uh you know
we come
out and and we we wake up with this
nightmare
um the thing eddie about our kids
we don't realize this until they reach a
certain age
it's like you you you you you assume
that you you built a very nice
skyscraper high-rise building and and
it's so fancy and you're dreaming it's
good
and by all the sudden it collapses why
because the root
or the uh foundation was rotten
and that's what happened to our children
and if we don't pay attention to their
education
uh it's it's very uh
dangerous uh quite frankly right now
uh i always say this line and i know it
can be offensive to many muslims
uh like you said at the very beginning
eddie that
oh i'm in america i'm i'm in paradise
i'm in heaven
and you know what many parents offer
their children
as a qurani to be here to be an american
as a sacrifice because their children
will lose their religion will lose their
faith will lose their
identity will lose their moral standards
in view of them staying here in the us
so we wanted to talk about to make a
contrast between
what is available a lot of times it's
it's across the board free it's free
education and you attribute
you know all the good things with
education but many parents are naive to
really what's happening on the ground
so let me also introduce now as i did
your names but also your titles
dr hassan you're the actual chairman
of the alternative of the solution
and also we have the principal principle
to that um solution also is dr ahmed
so you guys are offering so on one part
we are
showing and we're going to continue on
just kind of exposing
what the children are exposed to and i
opened up with that i knew
myself firsthand being someone who was
in the public institutions and i
remember
i don't remember exactly what year it
was in school
but i remember it was like valentine's
day
and then you know the children just
passing along you know what seems as
innocent
uh notes can i be your date to your
girlfriend and then kids at a young
age putting a jacket literally i saw as
the young kid is still embedded in my in
my brain
putting uh the jacket over their heads
and they're giving each other kisses
like
under the um the jackets you know and
the kids start actually dating they
start boyfriend and girlfriending you
know
at this young age right and not to
talk about what happens as you get older
because it's
it's just socially acceptable it's
something that these
innocent things i mean if you just i
don't know if you guys uh just recently
they had the
muslim hijabis and they had in this
netflix film called cuties have you guys
heard of that
yeah so all these things are happening
and they usually start in these public
institutions
uh dr hassan dr ahmed please uh
uh go ahead give us some of your uh
uh i mean let me just
agree with all what you said and just
before we we
talk about the uh the option or the uh
what we think is the
resolution uh to start with with all
these
uh problems that start with the muslims
and even though muslim
students uh getting exposed or children
getting exposed to such
a brutal uh like attack on the
immorality and on
uh the religion uh if you look at the
evolution of the
islamic education in uh in the u.s and
in the west
are you to find out that it started in
like big institutions that was based on
uh big support by uh dedicated members
of their communities
try to try to expand this model was
very difficult given the expenses
that incur was incurred with each
project uh given the
uh the wide spread of muslim children
everywhere
the scarce the scarcity of the or
the unavailability of the uh even the
islamic
education even sunday uh education or
sunday schools or
uh islamic institution which can teach
part-time quran and stuff like that
so gradually people start to
like put islamic schools together uh in
every community a promise that they are
very far
uh from where the clusters of muslims
are the
the resources are short because they
don't have enough funds so
you get by uh getting teachers who are
not qualified or not certified and they
are not good enough for the job
um you also have a challenge of a
financial
um like tuition or the tuition that the
parents cannot afford
let alone the transportation where they
can uh where they're gonna get to
these places in order to get their
children in there's a mistrust also with
the
most of the islamic schools because of
the results of the
uh the the exams the uh
the uh that they see when the children
are
in islam school compared to their peers
in the public school or private school
uh or have you that that's uh there's a
discrepancy so that
cause a mistrust between the uh muslim
parents and the islamic schools
led to almost islam schools either going
out of business or
they are cannot uh grow anymore or they
limit their
education to the sixth grade kids go to
the medic school after after this and
lose it
all uh getting uh hanging hanging around
with the wrong
peers so looking at that uh
we tried to uh have some resolution for
piece by piece how can we uh overcome
the all these uh things and uh
provide uh like a a could be a
really a radical uh like uh resolution
for all these problems that's islamic
school which
have challenges trying to um
to make when you mention islamic school
private school a lot of times the
complaints
that people say is that the children now
when they're
they their parents take them out of some
of these public institutions some of the
worst places they could be in from the
get-go they bring them into the
now the islamic school those kids start
to corrupt
the other kids and they start to bring
over the education
you know what they learn and i'm not
talking about the reading and writing
i'm talking about what they learned on
the streets what they learn from the
other kids they bring it in
and then they also learn how to put on a
double front a double mask
exactly exactly they're good in front of
the parents and teachers in the slum
school
they are somebody else afterwards the
other solution some of the parents
actually
tried to use using home schooling taking
their
kids through and putting them uh like at
home
and trying to uh use this and that in
itself it helps but
again it deprived the children from the
social skills from the ability to
associate or hang around with the right
peers and also take that very important
like piece of uh like the
sports extra curricular activities that
the schools
uh provide so that's not and you see
that i mean you can tell
even non-muslim kids when they are in
the homeschooling system or they have
homeschooling
you can see a difference in the
personality and looking down a little
bit the press they are not
as like up front talking to you as the
uh kids in the public schools uh the
prin
our principal or the principal dr ahmed
what do you think now what's the
difference
between what we're talking about and
what you are trying to offer
at the academy
as you we already discussed from the
beginning we had seen all these info
that been introduced our children to
destroy their personality
and to study their molar
morality we suffer
did uh establish
programs that can help our children to
grow right
to protect our kids and the children
from all these bad influences
we we can see that um
after kovit even though was very
difficult in all of us
but subhanallah
allah has something good in it for all
of us that we
uh when digital and we try to see the
best the digital platform
to help the children and we see the
necessity
of having good islamic school
uh alhamdulillah at safa we
establish and we plan
a system that can help our kids who are
at home or any masjid can learn
digitally and learn about allah learn
about their academics
and also in good discipline
environment you can see for example
and from seven to grid and dab the
classes will be based on gender
to allow the children to express
themselves as well
also we
focus on the principles of the sunnah
and the understanding of the deen to
help
our kids uh establish understanding
of their well-being and why they are in
this universe
to worship allah with that we are to
provide them with the tools
that can help them to succeed in
tomorrow's world and be able to compete
with their peers
doing that we alhamdulillah at safa
we had the business platform one of the
busy platforms to
use our educational programs for
academia
we have the also the ebooks that
covers all the topics math science
english social studies as well as
arabic as well as quran as well as
islamic studies
all of this will be made available to
our students to
learn first about their
their life as well as their lord
and they will be able to
compete with their peers and in really
enhanced their skills
and their understanding of the topics
that they are studying
and alhamdulillah we have the ebooks
which is digital books that very
rigorous curriculum
curriculum has a lot of alternative for
our children
starting from normal textbooks to videos
and a lot of videos that
illustrate the understanding and also
explain the meaning of the lesson itself
besides the the
teaching of the staff that would be life
teaching
that help our kids to grow this is uh
the part of
the the knowledge uh also
we added more
programs to help our children who are
really weak to make sure to give them
all the necessary skills that they need
and we also have a
a program to monitor and test our
children periodically
to see whether they are on the level of
the class or not
if they are not then the program will
direct the teacher to develop
a special program for the child
learning and help recover the deficit in
his understanding and then also his
learning
also those who would like to escalate
to excel those who are really gifted
and talented we also have programs for
them to help them also learn
better as well as excel uh
to the tub and also can
engage in uh the best
uh like educational programs
uh such as ap courses
also uh s.a.t
that help them to score well at the end
of their high or during high school so
all of these things
all of these things are covered there um
people can get more we'll tell them
where they can get more information
i want to bring on our special guest
just tuned in
i want to get uh this is an educator
of i believe over 20 some years
it's one thing for us to talk about
what i had in the video but
someone who is actually on the ground
someone who's
a professional an educator to bring some
of these things to light
to see the seriousness i want to bring
on our special guests to kind of really
let us know what is happening in these
public institutions
so they can see we're not making this
stuff up mrs lipsack how are you
good to see you ready i'm doing fine
all right um brenda how are you doing
how you been
doing doing okay fighting the fight
so we have brenda we have uh dr hassan
dr ahmed
and uh you know imam kareem so we wanted
to bring you on as our special guest
just to kind of give us
because it's one thing us talking about
it but then someone who's an educator
with so many years i believe it's uh 30
years of experience is that correct
yes close to 30 years now yeah so can
you give us a breakdown
and update on what is happening in the
current public education schooling some
of the things that the children are
being taught
yes right now it's ethnic studies and
critical race theory
is what has been um they're trying to
pass it as a graduation requirement
and as i read through the ethnic study
model curriculum
on the framework i was very concerned
because
i believe it's a trojan horse um using
race
as a smokescreen to bring in pedophilia
and let me explain why there's a
paragraph
um that they put in chapter three page
six
that basically says lgbtqia
plus is an ever-changing ever-expanding
spectrum of identities whereas more
identities can fall under this umbrella
in the future
um that's giving the state a blank check
as it relates to genders and sexualities
um so i sent a request because they gave
us some
a window of time to give input to the
state
and i requested that they um provide
one statement exempting pedophilia
or map which is called minor attracted
persons
that they would exempt that from any
future
alternative identities um and they
refuse to do so
uh imam kareem or dr salam hassan do you
guys uh
is there any specific questions that you
guys also
would like to ask uh brenda lipsack
let me begin uh brenda first of all you
look so nice in the hijab
and uh i hosted brendown on my show
eddie i don't know if you're aware of
that
we actually had a whole show and we
presented to our community
uh she really made me aware of
many uh scheming and blotting that is
being developed and
it's actually evolving now in a way that
it's no longer scheming or plotting
actually we see the
uh we see it in existence and this
actually one of the things that had me
uh approached dr hassan salah and
dr ahmed said him to
you know we were working on this program
but we wanted to do it
faster now and the qubit kind of helped
out
um so right now what we're doing brenda
is we're doing a virtual school uh
where we'll be teaching our muslim
children
online live teachers not
dealing with computers they're going to
have a live teacher teaching each class
uh we're encouraging them to be in a
center learning center so that they
don't miss on the
social uh aspect
the interaction the development of a
character because of the peer
and the association with their age
groups
but if you if they can then they can
just do it at home
uh we're giving these options to them
what we're doing is we're uh of course
we're accredited
uh school uh we're going because we want
our children to graduate and
go to college and and you know uh
because we still live in america uh so
what we're doing is we're
uh basically what and this is maybe dr
ahmed salem the principal
of the organization can help us with
that but we're doing something called
islamizing the
the curriculum we're looking into
every textbook and we're finding uh if
there is a moral defect
or a faith defect like that sentence
would may
be understood like there is no god no we
we fix that
we we we cannot remove it from the
textbook because we still after
accreditation
but we we work on the lesson plan we
have a unified lesson plan
which will will uh moral and and so
forth
uh what is the uh uh
my question comes here uh are we risking
anything are we doing something against
the law because we don't want to
uh you know go against the law of the
land we are
low binding citizens of america and we
want to stay this way
yes america is our country and i really
believe that we as muslims
are here beside you i know that you're
not a muslim yourself and we
we ask allah one day you will be um but
this is your choice
uh but this is the one difference that
we can give back to america you know
america given us
a whole lot we come we're immigrants the
three of us were immigrants
we appreciate this country so much you
know we we
we appreciate it so much you know but we
want to give something back
and this is what we want to give back to
america because we know
superpowers in the past falling apart
because
lack of faith lack of morals or are we
doing something against the law here i'm
asking you bluntly yes
well imam kareem um this is what we are
trying to do
um people of all faiths are coming
together and uniting to get school
choice on the ballot
because public education has betrayed
the trust of parents
and even though california is leading
the way for this
it's coming in um nationwide because
even in the national association of
education for young children
um it's part of the master plan for
universal preschool
and i read the glossary and under gender
identity it says that starting at age
three they want to teach children that
gender is fluid and expansive
so that is absolutely child abuse
and we need to stop it and if we have
school choice
and it goes um nationwide then
you're going to be given a lot more
freedoms and
so i i'm not a lawyer so i can't answer
exactly
those questions on how that works state
to state but i would say
vote for representatives and officials
that promote school choice and are not
endorsed by the teachers union
because the teachers union is against
school choice
they want to monopolize the educational
system for the sake of indoctrination
and you guys could watch some of the
previous episodes we did where we went
in depth
you know deep you know exposing we're
not exposing
what they had what the senators sinister
plots like you were saying
uh imam what she spoke to you about that
you can actually see
from from someone who has been working
in the educational system
and you can see in the previous shows
that i've done brenda also
has a now website is that correct where
are people
formed what is that it's called brenda
for kids the number four dot-com
yeah www.brenda4kid
and you can um get a hold of me that way
too i have an email address
contact um i did want to mention because
i know eddie you said if i have extra
information than before
new information which i do um
one is i've been doing research about
gender identity
and i found out the originator of who
came up with this
crazy notion his name is john
william money john william money
and if you google his name and do a
little research you'll find out that he
endorsed pedophilia
so this they're using all of these
genders
how how money how money is killed please
m-o-n-e-y wow what is that
what you said how is it spelled yeah no
no how do you build money i'm sorry i'm
just
no i'm just kidding well yeah it has a
lot to do with money i'm sure
but john william money he endorsed
pedophilia and i believe this is the way
they're using
gender identities as a stepping stone
towards pedophilia because
if they can get kids confused about
their gender at young ages then they
automatically
qualify and they go into the lgbtq
category because q stands for
questioning
so that puts them in that
grooming category miranda i have a
question for you
um one of the we tried in new jersey and
it looks like
we talked to some of the uh legislators
about
uh the place school choice in new jersey
it looks like one of the
uh their fears that if they give parents
the the choice to to of schooling their
kids
they're going to lose a lot of number of
kids that they're not going to attend
lucky schools and that will lead to
lack of funds for the public school cell
and then might compromise their programs
in the public schools
and i mean i it's just
i don't know how much do you think the
the effort of these groups who are
promoting
the uh the schooling choice
would be productive uh in in the face of
like the
status like in in in that i mean there
is like a top financial
um like um atmosphere that the the
united states is
is in because of the corona virus and
because of what we have been
through you think that there will be
some
uh like success in in that
on promotion of the uh the schooling
choice
well as far as public education um
because there's a monopolization
anytime there's a monopolization it
invites corruption
because it lacks accountability and when
there's competition
you have more accountability that's what
charter schools were doing and that's
why
teacher unions were passing laws in
california to stifle
the creation of charter schools which
were being very effective
i'm not saying they were all great but
charter schools were under
a much higher accountability system
because they had to be
renewed every five years that means that
if they weren't performing
or if parents weren't getting the
outcomes
that they would discontinue and that
doesn't happen in regular public schools
they can
they can um have kids that
most of the kids can't read and do math
and they just keep on going and
the way they're passing laws in
california they're now saying that
objective math is considered racist
that math should be based more on
feelings and has multiple
answers for whatever reason they're
really
they're dumbing down our academics and i
don't know
why but that's what's happening and we
we can't stand for it
brenda thank you so much for joining us
for this program and sharing
some of the insights we look forward to
having you back again on
on some future episodes thank you so
much good to meet you
and where's that again brenda that
people can go ahead and look up uh some
of uh
your work it's brenda for kids
brenda4kids.com yes
and if we get new some out of california
hopefully
i am trying to push for larry elder
because larry elder
wants to bring school choice into
california
thank you brenda thank you so much thank
you all right thank you brenda thank you
again
all right so wrapping up we're almost
out of time can i
can i uh wrap up quickly yes uh
eddie uh you know there is a famous
hadith in the sunnah
imam muslim hadith
which really explains the the story of
the people of the trench
uh if viewers are interested to find out
about
this hadith then they can go into the
explanation of suratul
basically uh our children are living
this particular
time now even though the the time of the
story was right after
uh prophet jesus peace be upon him was
raised up
uh basically uh this king wanted
a young boy to teach him
disbelief which is sorcery
because his chief sorcerer is about to
die
so you know he feels threatened if
if that system that moral collapse
system and the
uh no god system is is is doesn't
sustain itself he will lose his kingdom
so he looked for that child you know
that that that pioneer young man and
and subhanallah they willed for him to
be to lead the way
to continue leading the deception the
the people astray whether morally or
whether
faith-wise but subhanallah allah will
for this boy to be actually the reason
for the people to believe
so in his way out there he hears the
truth so
he's he's walking to learn falsehood
every day
but he heard that voice of truth out
there
and and he followed that voice and he
found that old shape
of course it's a monk according to them
but for us
was somebody on tahit running away
because he knows the truth
and his life is threatened and he
becomes so attracted to this truth
that he picked the sheikh or or the monk
you know to to to come every day and
learn from them
so imagine uh every day this young boy
gets a share of the truth
and the share of falsehood whether we
liked or not brothers and sisters in
islam
this is what your children are going
through your children are going to get
the falsehood
through the wi-fi through the google
through the yahoo through the
pornography site through the all these
they're gonna get it
through the atheist side they're gonna
get it it's
too much uh too hard
to control parental control doesn't work
anymore
you know what we're trying to do we're
trying to give them the second side of
the story
you know we want them to hear the second
that's all safa is about
we want them to hear the truth so maybe
you see this this truth that he heard
even though this young boy was hearing
the truth and falsehood
at the same day at the same time you see
in his way to
learn falsehood he learns the truth but
subhanallah
it led him to that you know at one stage
because those two cannot co-exist
together
you must have two hearts for those two
to exist and
and he faces this this situation where
he takes a rock and then he makes this
dua
he said oh allah which one do you love
more the
the truth of the shaykh or the the
disbelief of the sorcerer
if you love what the sheikh has been
teaching me then kill that little
that lion with that little rock that i
have and
it was allah guided him for that's what
we're trying to do we're trying to get
your children to hear the second
side of the story the other side of the
story
uh you you probably brainstormed a lot
of parents
they don't realize this but there is
another side of the story out there that
your children have to hear
now safa which is salah deen future
academy by the way that's what stands
for
deen the famous figure which is really
favored by the west
uh sofa came in with the solution when
we talk to parents about sending their
kids to islamic schools
the first thing that comes up i have a
free education
and these are excellent buildings
they want me to they cannot afford the
tuition
right now that tuition is in in some
states a thousand dollars
imagine so if you have three four
children so we worked on that
we worked on that the human resources
eddie
like in colorado here we have a perfect
uh people ready but we don't have the
teachers
we don't have enough teachers so now
we're gonna we created that platform
that
if chicago has good teacher he's going
to teach the one in
if if new jersey has one if
so we worked in this as well also some
problem that we had in the past
is the discrepancies between what is
being taught
yes standardization you know like this
guy goes to that school
and then he learns god is everywhere and
then he goes to the other school
god is above the throne which one you
know and they they they meet one another
in the youth groups
which one no we have a unified
curriculum
a global national curriculum we have by
the way
five campuses so far and we're
recruiting more
the second thing is we're encouraging uh
children giving actually special
discounts if you if you form learning
centers
especially around the masjid because we
want the children to hear the adam
we want them to interact with one
another by the way brothers and sisters
in islam
were not talking about dealing with a
computer you're going to have a live
teacher on the other side
some live teacher you will have islamic
studies you're going to have
you're going to have arabic and imagine
we're recruiting our arabic teachers
from uh
the muslim world why because and they
speak good english too
they will they will teach in english so
what we're trying to do we're trying to
come around the whole
dilemma of education make it simple for
you
and imagine 295
dollars and we actually and this is just
if your child is going to learn at home
but we 250 if you're going to learn if
you're going to form a learning center
somewhere and uh even that with dr
hassan
allah we can even offer more help to
balance but
if you can afford that that's the least
and and no compromises to the education
so safa usa it's it's it's there for you
brothers and sisters in islam
you have no reason to uh not to uh do
something about the education of your
children inshallah
uh www s
usa salahuddin
future academy which is safa usa america
it's a national art global.org
and the phone number one eight seven
seven three seven
one safa one eight seven seven
three seven one safa give us a call
in sha allah we have already campuses
set one in colorado
uh one in uh in pittsburgh
a couple in new jersey and we're working
with people in california
and we're working with people in seattle
in sha allah we're recruiting more
all what you need to do is have a place
where offering the ebooks
uh they're gonna be delivered to you of
course the children the students have to
pay for it
but what you need is a tutor someone who
sits with the children make sure that
they are
communicating with the teacher on the
other side so this is what we're talking
about here we're trying to offer
solutions to a contemporary present
problem we ask allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
to bless dr
salah
experience and by the way he already
checked out whether we were doing things
legally or not he knows that we're doing
things legally but i was like
trying to sweeten up with brenda there
so uh alhamdulillah we have a good team
together
uh i'm taking care of the religious
aspects the curriculum making sure that
what is taught is
in accordance with the quran and sunnah
based on the understanding of the first
three
generations so we're looking forward i
have my children
by the way this is i'm doing this for my
children and whatever
i mean besides whatever benefit other
muslim children
but i want to save my kids you know
because i know
one day i will stand in front of allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala on boatmen day
and he will ask me what did you do
regarding the education of your children
what did you do regarding the protecting
the identity of your children
all right so wrapping up here we know
that everything will stay behind
from this life and one of the things
that stays behind
is and that's beneficial for us as a
righteous child a child that's going to
make dua for you when you leave
this life and what's the point of
raising your children and then putting
them in an
institution that they end up losing
themselves they lose their deen
so we went the first part of it exposing
to many parents
who just don't know educating them on
some of the things that are happening in
the public institutions
we brought in a surprise guest to also
even go deeper
into the attack on the little minds you
know the changing of the genders and all
the other
immoral things that are promoted along
with the greatest evil
that there's no creator that there's no
god so why would i put my child into an
institution like that when i can put my
child into an institution like we're
discussing today
the alternative suffer so with that
being said
any last closing comments and
suggestions now or
a piece of advice dr hassan dr ahmed
we got one minute left why should
parents go ahead and enroll their
children
into the self academy i mean
it's it's very very important that you
choose who your child is hanging around
with
uh if they're hanging around with the
right muslim kids the right peers
they're going to be part of them they're
going to be a long friendship and long
brotherhood
or sisterhood with them and that will
carry like would bring
a new generation bring very strong
new muslim generation that they have
arms that connecting each other they are
like growing with each other and the
helping each other in
difficult situation that will minimize
the exposure of time
that these kids are being exposed to
non-muslim
uh like and the other systems that might
destroy
their morals their uh behavior their
uh their values and uh like bring
a completely entirely different
offspring that they don't know their
religion or they're confused about their
religion it has to do with who
your friend your child will be friend
with and that
will insha allah fix a lot of what we
have with our children
and dr ahmed
jazakum i think until all the parents
all those who hear us after you uh heard
all of that
i i i will invite you to visit
safarusa.org
and to call us and let your kids
enjoy these kind of programs
and make sure to
select for your kids what they are going
to learn
and we here were at safa are
going to take care of their kids right
maintain
all the academic standards and
help your kids to exceed and insha allah
we are gonna make sure your kids
are progressing every day and inshaallah
will communicate with you
at all times to make sure you are aware
of your
kids education not only that our
platform
are controlled and also secured
that your kids will be during classes
secured
even after that they will be able to
learn
without any interference from other
websites or other programs and inshallah
we ask allah to protect our children and
help us to do the job right and give
them the best education inshallah
www.safa usa.org
say that again it's safer s a f a
dot org w w w suffer
s a f a
u s dot org u s aid
usa dot org so s a f
a u s a dot org uh
just don't forget uh also kareem that
you have an open house for
uh that uh exemplary uh inshallah
center that's uh developing or evolving
in
uh colorado is gonna be the first year
for uh for denver
to have that center for safa and also
there's going to be an open house
in mid-august for vineland new jersey to
just invite everyone to either online or
to come in person to see our centers and
to see what we offer to
children you know eddie uh what
something a blessing about
this project is the spirit of working
together
yes you know you know subhanallah that's
a blessing
and we're coming together to save our
children
you know uh so alhamdulillah allah is a
blessing that allah is using us uh
to do this it's an honor allah and honor
it's it's a very ca
we're so grateful to you allah to allow
us to be
a means to save a child i mean
let me ask you this now if uh and this
is the last question
if you have some christians the people
of other faith and they're also
getting fed up with all the immorality
the teaching
of that there's no god in the schools
and they're tuning in they're fans of
the dean's show and they're like you
know what i want to send my kid to safar
we we welcome them too i mean we're
teaching
they believe in one god and they believe
in all the messengers
you know this is not just exclusive i
mean this is no
people uh who want to raise their
children up on
one god on a moral message
honoring your parents not learning the
language like i talked about f-bombs in
the beginning
right away from bad company bad friends
you know drugs
you know the male female you know and
then
all the other genders eliminating that
just how the creator wants us to live
this is what you guys are preaching and
teaching at the school education
of god the oneness of god people can go
ahead and
come and join beside it's accredited
school
it's not something that is you know out
there
we have an accreditation so it is
you know something that is recognized by
the educational system okay
all right beautiful beautiful thank you
guys thank you so much may god almighty
the creator allah bless this project and
as you'll never know
thank you for having us thank you very
much thank you very much and
thank you all you heard it right there
for people who are sick of
all of the corruption that's going on in
these institutions and you're sending
your precious little ones the precious
little minds
into these places then you're losing
they're losing their minds
and you want to preserve your family you
want to preserve your children
go ahead and check out sofa go ahead and
check out sofa
and see what the alternative is to all
this
and we'll see you next time here on the
dean show until then peace be with you
assalamu alaikum subscribe if you
haven't already we'll see you next time
peace salaam alaikum